aha hello everybody my name is Mark
Larne welcome back to human fall flat
the horrible monstrosity that is known
as me is back again once again to haunt
your dreams
so I'm gonna continue on this way well
[ __ ] I was hahahahaha my balls okay I
wasn't supposed to do that I'm supposed
to actually climb up on the ledge
because that would be the smart thing to
do so let's put this back where it was
supposed to be and then not do [ __ ] up
with my stupidity so I'm gonna get to
the end of this level you're gonna see
me get there in montage style because
I'm not gonna subject you guys to my own
horribleness more than I have to I mean
there's nothing I like more than
subjecting you to how stupid I am and
bad games but right now I want to be
serious about this and we're gonna make
some progress
oh yay right and launch make it oh I
didn't even need my arms I can do this
with no arms human fall flat pop oh I
need to pause there
saved myself real good alright new area
show me what you got is that my chateau
is that the place I live and this is
this is the impossibility of how it is
to get there oh you know nice quiet
neighborhood very uh low trip what the
hell okay that's a physic base doodad
I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make it I'm
gonna make it I'm gonna make it huh yes
on the bed okay I made that I think I
can make this maybe maybe if I thrust my
belly upon it and my grundle it'll push
it off into the abyss hooray I did
something
[ __ ] did I do seriously all I did was
get it stuck well that's it
stupid try this I'll put yours in the
air be creepy and horrifying as fast as
you can
ah brueski yeah I made it
oh that's it just enough so that I can
do snack yes okay that's good god I
gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta got it
OOP okay ah finally up to my chateau my
isolated place in the middle of the
mountains hello me that beautiful face
of mine and my weird beard neck steaks
neck beard to the whole new level ah yes
my lovely home ding ding dong oh it's a
pull never mind anyway everything's
a-okay just gonna that's how I normally
walk in my own door ah good my TV I can
relax didn't I see a tutorial where I
flipped over couches in rage yep no I
just want to redecorate a little bit God
that fix needs to stop getting so close
ah ok good
ah [ __ ] my chateau betrayed me ass
annoyed damn it
Oh at least this time at least this time
I had cushioned cushioning my fault so
am I gonna have to pull down these
boards or do I just jump through the
window here Hey oh I'm struggling
futility diligence lead ha Barsky oh god
damn it this glass I just wanted to give
it a few swift humps before I was done
uh ha ha I'm flailing in desperation
there's got to be a way to pull these
off right maybe maybe not head I'm
giving it all the bull [ __ ] my butt
muscles are stronger than I ever thought
they could be all right then get the
other one here huh work it yeah oh man
work to destruction ooh boy I get to
make a big swinging metal thing go bang
smash it
well that did absolutely Jack diddly
what the Frick I wasn't even looking and
you blew up can you actually do the
destruction I got my face pointed
towards it all right whatever yeah
ah Rage Against the Machine take that
couch cushions you sons of [ __ ]
okay all righty then oh don't mind me
I'm just dreaming thrust my body ever so
gently up against things what about you
ha bunk no no oh that one worked okay I
just needed to be more desperate about
things great good to know why are these
still up ah
boink can I climb up here no can I push
him over No
can I do anything with my life No great
happy to know how I stand when things
are grim
mr. Gorbachev give me a freaking hand
here okay there we go got it whoa huh
I'm a rule breaker I'm a rebel baby I'm
gonna jump on that giant swinging ball
cuz when I see balls well that that was
easy I did it oh I didn't even need to
try on the greatest oh hello oh that's
you okay never mind then man there's
another part of the human experience
watching the degradation of society and
everything that we've built crumble -
around us is this what you meant by
human fall flat human civilization fall
flat hello is anybody here I hope I hope
I hope there's another human here for me
to enjoy the company out haha
haha okay oh good it's another dumpster
then i'ma throw off the edge of the
world goodbye I have a feeling I'm
supposed to well I wasn't supposed to go
with it
ow every non bone that I have has been
shattered and my leg is in this god damn
it let go let go help police
somebody Aisha Tyler oh where did I go
now well good thing I got this ride I'll
never be alone again
now that I got my friend dumpee here can
I please could I I don't know what's
happening I don't know what's going on I
don't know I'm supposed to be doing kind
of got barber knocked here can you let
go my goddamn ankle
roaring goddamn second I'll take you
with me you bastard anywhere you want to
go hey miss ki ha busy to give me the
notion whoops I want going the big wheel
[ __ ] ow
broke my everything yeah okay
I'll [ __ ] you come on man eat me one up
thief come on can I swing ball me swing
big ball me get momentum first hmm okay
meet me get momentum me momentum okay
well that's not quite going as planned
and now me I'm going to swing big ball
yeah I'm going to this this is not fast
this is opposite of fast any mana now
and born that was just a warning the
love tap was meant to show my emotions
and now you're gonna get the full brunt
from the other side oddly enough there
we go I broke you from the inside I got
you on my side and then I showed you
what was really what were and now I'm
gonna get ya what do I do with this I do
it this box crap
am I supposed to get this over there how
the hell am I supposed to do that I
can't make it
they're impossible I give up Oh made it
never mind
hey hey [ __ ] I broke it
oh well too bad I ain't paying for it
him come with me if you want to live
come with me if you you're a box and you
don't really [ __ ] I didn't even know
that there was glass there
oh well that's as much how much I don't
care about society giving it there's no
one else here
alrighty then where the hell am I going
now if there was like any semblance of
story to this like Who am I why am I
here and why was there a narrator
talking about the human existence and
what seemed like the futility of human
existence oh I know and I need to do I
need to destroy I need to destroy break
down the poles of society oh that almost
smashed my face right open oh well okay
open semi open feather me and you better
stay open or else I'm gonna be very
upset
oh no no no [ __ ] open please please open
maybe I could Wed one of these in there
it seems like it might be designed for
that exact idea hey let go of that thank
you
okay almost got it almost got it I'm
just gonna rub my growing up against it
a little more I'm the only man in the
world I'm not even sure I'm human okay
miss hello there we go stay that way you
better stay I'll come back and smile at
you no one likes that no one likes that
where's this going and why is this going
I need to get that box how do I get the
box what's in the box
the hell happened there ah good enough
whatever Hey
yes no no no huh hang on hang on let me
really think about this before I do
anything I wouldn't want to be too
impulsive about saving my own life here
I made it okay happy had did - Beth yeah
happy I don't know how I'm gonna get
this box back but I'm more try my best I
put a [ __ ] have but put okay all right
now what I didn't think this one through
matter baby
okay everything's fine knit knit hey
bird heard the Buchman
achtung habit dip up I don't know how
I'm gonna do this pop oh I did it
congratulations being on the greatest
ever was ha ha oh [ __ ] ah not the way I
anticipated victory to be claimed in ha
ha oh god oh god oh god I don't want to
reset it I don't want to do it again I
can make it I'm swinging more and more
precariously ah there's a nightmare
let's go down nightmare get up there god
damn it just get up there you sack a
crap don't grab under there grab up wrap
up that [ __ ] did it reset it oh good
thank goodness gravy I don't know I
didn't just jump from up here cuz I'm a
freaking idiot ha no I made it didn't
even need to grab on whoa
oh man I'm amazing look at me no human
falling flat here human go through door
human claim victory human don't know
where I am
where is who man hello hey I don't know
if I was supposed to go this way maybe
that's clues to the story in the
environment wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute isn't this back where I
was what the half this back where I was
get up there you can get up there get up
there back a crap what is that gonna do
for you why is there one more couch
cushion up there what does it matter up
why did I come up here why did I come to
get this is a load of baloney here huh
uh I'm gonna take this with me no I'm
not through this through this noise if
I'd have known that there was a secret
round here I would have gone here in the
first place I don't even know if I can
get back ah
Teddy sprinkles mommy mommy mommy [ __ ]
ah crap
oh crap your other goddamn hand up there
get it up there you sassy [ __ ] there we
go thank you for cooperating Eddie hit
me did me okay so this seems important
let me wreck this well [ __ ] balls where
did I go ow that almost hit me I gotta
climb up the damn thing again what a ass
you broke it you [ __ ] oh well I don't
know what to do about this
maybe I could throw one of these rocks
at this wall and break it with my super
strength ha
No try again ha
No one more time ought to do it again
threes the rule apparently I did not
expect that to work in any way but I'm
much stronger than I anticipated I don't
even need to do this I can probably
break it with my bare hands get out of
here get out there I said get out of
there oh I shouldn't stand in the way
that would have made things a bit
interesting yay physics alrighty then
i'ma go now obviously not over here
cuz I'm not gonna make this jump have a
river nevermind I made it with ease oh
[ __ ]
its class who defunct it who'da thunk
you swing back here never mind
ah frack I think it broke anyway just
because I willed it yes with my sheer
force of mind alrighty then I guess I
didn't need to do anything after all I'm
not an active participant in this game
everything's just gonna happen without
me oh god oh god that's class [ __ ] bag
ass [ __ ] ow every part of my body got
blown okay this time it's not gonna suck
yay didn't suck Oh cousin I've lived it
how gluten McGovern the Easy Bake Oven
well that doesn't help me cuz I don't
have a thing haha oh yeah okay so is
there gonna be a foreman in here that I
can complain to because I'm pretty sure
that this is against union laws hello
anybody home I'm so angry whoa
pull it all down Oh is a door nevermind
then I thought it was a breakable object
it probably was but then again I put I
could have realized that from the get go
get out of my face yeah that's what you
get
I'll break it anyway like I give a [ __ ]
well [ __ ] I also came in to a problem uh
titty sprinkles
I just don't slam that down and rage and
then find a way to raise that bridge up
okay don't know where I'm going again
but here I go
ah sack Afric room where Emmy go Emmy
cross this that seemed me right good
maybe I don't know if I'm supposed to go
across this I am going to fall going to
fall going to fall going to fall going
to fall going to fall going to fall yes
I made it I made it to a broken area
because this pipe obviously if it isn't
complete yep I don't even know if I was
supposed to be up here but this is good
enough for me huh oh that was a ladder I
could just easily climb that up but I
like my way better huh hmm okay here we
go
is this what I was supposed to do is
this where I was supposed to be probably
not I don't even see a control up here
this seems like I shouldn't be here
great maybe I could just climb over it
anyway who needs this if I can just go
on the pipe can I just go around the
entire level I mean who needs to go
through this I certainly do not
ah [ __ ] hip you know get get that higher
up
half there we go yeah I mean I'm not
gonna be one to mince words here I'm oh
yeah hon I will always love you get up
thank you okay back on top of things I'm
not gonna fall like a goober how the
hell am I supposed to be I'm just gonna
bypass everything don't mind me I have a
funny feeling I was probably supposed to
use this at one point I just didn't do
it at the right point and it out of that
day yeah I get up there yay okay good
enough for me
how do I get out of there maybe I sigh
if I just jump from the side I'd be able
to get around but I have a funny feeling
it's not gonna be too polite about that
if I don't go about at the right word II
maybe almost hey what does that do oh
that seems like it was supposed to do
something but then I didn't do it
so [ __ ] ah oh there's like a switch down
there okay boom got it okay that did a
thing and that's good maybe come on go
down here now investigate this doodad
whatever the hell it does I'll get out
of the way glass son of a biscuit nope
this does absolutely dick diddly there
was no point to any of that ah oh I get
it I get it I get it I know I know I
know I know what I'm supposed to do I
know I know what I'm supposed to do I'm
supposed to swing swung and if I swing
enough shuang's I'll make it through
okay so I just got to get the physics of
it it's just like when I was on the
playground long ago as a little child
even though this piece of glass is being
shoved up my taint
great that's getting in the way of my
momentum haha [ __ ] you Oh get out of the
way out of a
[ __ ] son of a [ __ ] stop it it keeps
bonk in the tips of my legs stop it hey
hey
almost there almost there
here we go oh [ __ ]
Megan god damn it [ __ ] me in the
butthole stupid piece of glass is it out
of the way yet god damn it
that's son of a [ __ ] glass get out of
here yeah okay mommy mommy I want
another ride [ __ ] I missed mommy I broke
my legs and got shards of glass in my
teeth here we go okay this time this
time everything's gonna work out
perfectly no shards of glass in the way
here we go almost not quite little more
yes I did it okay
now we got it going somewhere don't know
holy [ __ ]
we're on missed this literally missed
I'm pretty sure this is missed let me
just get through here I'm gonna bash it
with it rock it student giving me a
weapon [ __ ] missile yeah that's just a
warning hub nut on that quiet
urban not happening nope hey I did it
okay I'm gonna push off in these doors
and see what wandered never mind it's a
pole again goddamnit a little piece of
lock-in there that really what's gonna
stop me from escaping this this little
piece of Lock here really this is I was
gonna work okay got it
alright now I shall see where I am and
what I [ __ ] I shall see where I am
oh boy hey I'm in another goddamn
courtyard brick me okay here we go now
we shall see whoa hey okay this is
legitimately like Miss OH
do I get to toss myself at a catapult
yes please oh please tell me I can do
that
I want to do it I want to believe I
really want to believe make it in here
pup [ __ ] not quite almost so if I if I
crank this down a bit more ah okay yeah
okay all right okay all right okay all
right
okay here we go three two one four five
seven six Wow oh [ __ ] ow
all right so that's the end of human
fall flat for now there's obviously more
stuff to be done but I don't know if I
should continue let me know if you want
to see more in the comments below
there's probably more interesting ways
to use this bizarre physics system in
the next few levels so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye probably doesn't translate into you
guys here so I could be your friend I'll
just pan you about a little bit